fallacy which has been propagated by
gender ideologues and is doing profound
damage to gay people among others in our
society as well as women
I can't quite hear you I can hear you
muttering something a poll that just got
published in the United States showed
that among the general population
support for gay marriage has been
starting to decline in the last year why
is that it's because the arguments that
actually brought about liberal rights
for all minorities in last few decades
have started to get turned on their head
and turned against people what is the
source of that it is the gender ideology
movement what is the tripwire for the
general public it is children and so a
backlash is starting and the backlash is
coming because people are lying to
children and are using children for
medical experiments one day The
Barbarians will be at the gate and we
will be debating which gender pronouns
to call them